lindsay is with us lindsay's in houston
texas hi lindsay how are you
doing well i'm excited to be on just a
little bit nervous but thank you for
having me
well we're honored to have you um
well i completed fpu in 2017 and after
doing so
i paid off my car i've increased my
savings and investments
i don't have any other debt and i'm
currently renting
i am going back to school to get my phd
and my school will be completely paid
for through
grants and graduate assistantships and i
will also have a monthly stipend but
that means i'll be on a fixed income so
um and i'm also needing to move
to august i mean to the area in august
and so
the rental rates are pretty high in
college stations so i'm looking at
purchasing my parents are offering um
they're being extremely generous and
offering to help me buy a house they're
actually
also debt free and went there to see you
in 2014 to do their debt free screen
cool so you're going to a m to get a phd
in what
uh educational psychology and then what
are you going to do
i want to teach at the college level
where at a
i don't know how long does a phd program
take
i'll be there for three years don't buy
a house
okay yep that was my question okay
because you listen a phd program i don't
know anything about it i've only got one
and
you know i've got a phd in dumb but
john's got a couple of them and i
rumor is it that they're tough to get
it's a lot of work the jobs after no no
the getting of the degree the whole
process that the dissertation the whole
thing right
yes yeah and then being an educational
psychologist that's a
yeah to get it to get a tenure-track job
is going to be tough and you know that
walking into it
but the chances of you landing in
college station
and and working there after that degree
are very very small
i don't want you concentrating on home
ownership i want you concentrating on
the completion of the phd
and then quickly moving to the place
that gives you a job that's right
okay and that was my question was with
the short-term nature if it was smart
to buy or not exactly it's college town
it's college town and college towns are
college towns uh
you know they're gonna go through a
metamorphosis in the next five years
because people are not going to college
like they used to
right so it's going to affect real
estate in a small town like college
station
in a major way yeah okay
okay i i do have one other question
should i stop
do i know it sounds silly but do i stop
contributing to my roth ira since i'm
going to be on such a sick and someone
do i try
as best i can to continue that your
stipend do you have to pay taxes on that
is that a fi is that considered earned
income
it is yeah then you then you do have an
earned income you can do a roth
you can only do a roth though if you are
guaranteed that you're not going to have
any debt
due to this education because i want you
to i want you to invest in you
before you invest in mutual funds
right okay yeah i should not have
everything should be
um covered because i'm technically
working as well for the university
and that's paying for my school yeah and
if that ended what would you do
uh if then paying for me ended yeah
i would have to get another job yeah
okay
and so you do you you'd find another way
to pay for you know
i don't mind if you if you stop your
your retirement temporarily in pile up
cash to complete this
this education and not that you're
necessarily gonna need the cash
but if you end up with 15 or 20 000
bucks or 50 000 bucks or whatever in a
savings account when you come out it's
not going to kill you
no that's that's your house down payment
yeah right if wherever whatever you're
going to live or you roll that over into
your retirement once you get settled
somewhere yeah you know that that's
that's the process hey but that's man
talk about you
doing it right there's not that's an
outstanding school it's an outstanding
program one of my
mentors graduated from that very program
for that very school it is top notch and
you get well and when you can get a
fellowship like that and they pay you
something you get through that debt-free
you you've won
that's the touchdown that's outstanding